en la década de los 80 y 90 durante 12
años fue el terror de perú y llegó a
estar cerca de arrodillar al gobierno
peruano abimael guzmán fue el líder
absoluto de sendero luminoso una
guerrilla maoísta que contó con 10 mil
soldados ya la que la comisión de la
verdad peruana responsabilizó del 54 por
ciento de las 70 mil muertes
consecuencia del conflicto
corresponde
esa imagen en una jaula y con ropa de
presidiario derrumbaba el mito de lo que
fue antes de su detención le llamaban
presidente gonzalo fue profesor de
filosofía y eligió en torno a su persona
un culto mesiánico se consideraba a sí
mismo la cuarta espada del marxismo tras
marx lenin y mao y muchos creyeron que
guzmán llegaría a ocupar el palacio
presidencial y establecer sus tesis del
comunismo más ortodoxo sin embargo hasta
amnistía internacional antes de su
último juicio pidió la máxima condena
esperamos que después de haber seguido
este proceso que en algún momento nos ha
parecido lento pero que ha respetado el
debido proceso se llegue a una sentencia
absolutamente severa y como la cadena
perfecta en que la llegada al poder del
ultraderechista alberto fujimori
exacerbó un conflicto que terminó con la
detención de abimael guzmán en 1992
desde entonces estuvo en la base militar
del callao fue condenado a cadena
perpetua por un tribunal militar
sentencia que fue declarada
inconstitucional en 2003 y como había
pedido el director de amnistía nacional
fue ratificada en 2006 por un tribunal
civil un encierro que la defensa
calificó de absoluto
sendero luminoso terminó su actividad en
el año 2002 sin embargo el legado de
abimael todavía perdura entre fanáticos
del guerrillero que llegó a creerse el
mesías de perú